men do have a cycle it just happens to
be 24 hours they do go through similar
phases during the day they go to bed
during their menstrual phase they wake
up in their ludial phase it's kind of a
backwards situation and then they're
kind of in the afternoon they're in an
ovulatory social verbal phase morning
testosterone cortisol surge for them is
where they're doing their deep focused
high concentration work then in the
afternoon they have their testosterone
cortisol drop and stamina so this is
something they have to compensate for
they do with caffeine they do with other
nootropics and but it's also why
corporate culture has happy hour around
this time because this is when men have
a little bit more access to their
estrogen which makes them more verbal
and social but then after dinner
they're now in their lowest phase of
hormones which is exactly what
menstruation phase is the bleeding phase
right the lowest levels of all your
hormones they need to go into the
whatever their version of a man cave is
and go to sleep in order for them to
make testosterone for the next day
this podcast exists because i love
talking to people and i love going deep
the purpose is to plant seeds of
inspiration we enter a space of
vulnerability and relatability and what
you realize is that we are so much more
alike than we are different to quote
ramdas we're all just walking each other
home and this show is just one step i'm
danica patrick and i'm pretty intense
thank you for joining us we have elisa
vidi on the show today she is an
integrative nutritionalist hormone
expert
best-selling author of woman code she
also wrote in the flow which is a book
that i read and the creator of the cycle
sinking method she is on the leading
edge as a pioneer which we talked about
at the very beginning of the
conversation
in this field of women and our cycle
and hormones and how we can better
live to
address our
natural well-being
uh by following this cycle sinking
method by following for women these four
cycles that happen throughout the month
and what's before anyone any guys depart
after hearing what i've just said so far
she talks a lot also about a guy's cycle
and how the 24-hour cycle that a man has
so
did you know as women that and men also
because let's face it some of you are
going to end up with a woman you might
carry you have a mom you have a sister
whatever birth control is a synthetic it
does not allow you to have an actual
cycle like stuff like that that you know
you just think we would know and i
didn't know until i read the book it's
really a drastic education on how we
need to look at operating in our daily
life to maximize and not even just like
maximize for what we know but maximize
beyond what we've even achieved so far
to create
a really holistically balanced and
elevated life from top to bottom in
every aspect well it's an honor to meet
you i like any um woman who's doing the
like trailblazing stuff so it's just
great yes thanks you're trailblazing too
yes you know i that's why i think you
know we're in good company right that's
sort of my favorite
i i
i enjoy other women who do things that
are first of their kind and i i
aspire to to do my part in whatever way
i can as well
do you feel like
the trailblazing that you're doing is
something that you
like felt like you like a responsibility
to do
um and like a vulnerability but you kind
of felt like you had to do it or was
this just like your path
i think it's a combination of
an organic evolution
of sort of the things that have unfolded
but also
uh key
pivotal eye-opening moments
that sort of made me realize that i
wanted to be an advocate for women
so i had both a health care
kind of
awakening for my own self but i also had
like a feminist awakening at a certain
point as well and
and then i i think they sort of merged
in a way and i somehow i'm able to
offer that up through my
entrepreneurship
i read your book and i and in the flow
and i
i could feel that sort of um
like it always takes
when you're shifting
shifting things sometimes it takes a
little bit of like a yo-yo going far
enough one direction to kind of pull it
back but there was like a a feeling of
one of wanting to reclaim
and like
foot down like look at me look at us
like we are
why do you why are you
putting this misinformation out or lack
of information out and acting like it's
for the masses and it was almost like uh
it was kind of like waving your hands in
the air kind of feel
uh to
especially obviously based on what
you're what you go what you do the
medical side of females and how
everything manifests for females and how
women in their cycle cycle
period of their life which is what six
fifth fourteen to
fifty uh something like a good solid
four decades yeah
yeah and how i i can feel that and was
there something that happened that made
you
realize just how
unrepresented
um women in their
in their uh fertile phase of their life
were or just women in general because
it's really not just
it kind of had like a whole woman feel
is there a story is there a moment
you can only do so much when you're
constantly hit with data points right
where you just you know
i don't know
just the way i'm wired like you have to
take action when you're seeing
statistic after statistic after you know
trend after institutionalized gender
bias like you just
it just paints a story or tells a story
and paints a picture that um
we're being
left out of research we're being
unseen
underserved in the conventional and
frankly any healthcare model
and that the statistics of the women who
are suffering for these hormonal issues
throughout these four decades which
includes not just menstruation but
fertility and perimenopause
that's just a statistic that keeps
growing and i
feel compelled
to do something about it and it's not
just that i feel compelled it's that
also
there's that sort of side of me that's
sort of absorbing all the statistics and
the data but then there's the side of me
as the academic and the researcher who's
looking and saying there's a way out
so
let's acknowledge that there's a
flaw
in the model that we are operating in
around our hormonal health care let's
just acknowledge that which you know
sort of do in the first couple chapters
of the book but then let's just move
forward and here's the correct
information and here's how to do it
and let's expect better
for our health
and our health care as women and the i
fundamentally know that the sort of
uh ripple effect of that for women goes
well beyond uh just what
how it impacts their health you know
short term and long term it's really a
whole life shift
you know just the other day i was doing
a
webinar for moms with teenage daughters
and you know how do you deal with your
daughter's pms right and i said well the
most important thing that you have to do
as a mom if you have a young daughter
start to have a conversation with her at
nine
you know i have a my daughter will be
seven
in the fall
and
you know she already understands some of
these basic things right i've been
educating her in my own way can only
imagine what having me as a mom would be
like
a girl
so
i you know at nine though you know we're
gonna have a whole conversation about
you know different biological rhythms
and that for her
you know at a certain age you know
12-ish
what i want the focus to shift from is
not talking about oh you're going to
have this thing happen around bleeding
just really it isn't serving any purpose
it puts the focus on the wrong thing
that's a part of the story
but unfortunately that part of the story
has been so co-opted by the
negative millennia-old
curse conversation
that
i think we could do better to serve our
young you know women by telling them
instead okay actually around 12 this
whole new biological clock is going to
get activated in your brain and affect
every system of your body
and
it's going to give you huge advantages
in creativity and energy and immunolog
immunological response and everything
else
but you have to make one key switch when
this happens oh really what's the switch
that i have to make like i'm just
imagining this dialogue between a mom
and a daughter okay well the switches
you go from taking care of yourself the
same way every day
to changing your self-care routine four
times a month and i'll show you how to
do that when the time comes but i just
want you to be prepared that this super
amazing brain body thing is going to
happen to you and it only happens to
girls and how cool is that
if we had that conversation
at nine
and then you know actually giving the
practical
how-to of the cycle syncing method at 12
making that the focus of menstruation
like now here's menstruation
now you have your clock you can set your
timer for self-care to those four phases
start doing it start tracking your
cycles or doing so you get a 12 year old
girl biohacking
essentially building a positive
relationship with her body
then we just kind of bypass all the
patriarchal wounding and kind of just
quickly get out of what typically
happens at that age which is
some form of trauma right because if you
haven't been prepared for what is going
to shift in your body you can register
that in many different negative ways
that affects your health your psychology
and frankly the trajectory of your life
so it's exciting to think
about um
what could change for women
uh at any age when they figure this out
but especially what could happen when we
sort of really
model this
for the young women in our lives yeah
and give them a different platform
because it's it's the cur it's correct
to do that and it's what young men get
to have access to and we know how how
advantageous that is for them
so
they theirs is pretty simple right i
mean i think this is what was
fascinating is fine learning how and i
don't think i mean like micro macro
whatever call it an a similarity like
women are complicated and no i reject
that i'm sorry i reject that you reject
that i reject that phrasing because it's
not true it's not true that is a great
example
of cultural conditioning and accent in
action right
you live in your own body
right the only reason that you would
call it complicated is because you
haven't been given a proper tour
right like if you were to say to me
elisa please
come to my house and go get me the um
sweater that i want
i'd be like oh no that's complicated
which room in the house is it which
drawer is it is it in a closet i don't
know where to go and what to do to do
this that feels complicated and
overwhelming
exactly the same thing if you haven't
been given the blueprint of how your
body works you are making an inaccurate
assumption
that you are complicated which you are
not you are extremely logical and easy
to understand but who's who's telling
you what how it works no one
men are equally complex
as women's biology is right
in a different way they're just it's
just two different patterns
but why would we judge one pattern as
easier or more efficient and one as more
complex or complicated or problematic or
mysterious if it only the only reason we
would do that is a cultural conditioning
what the narrative has been your whole
life running in the background of your
life about the differences between men
and women so i reject that and i
challenge any woman
to really start to look at what is that
inner dialogue and that script that
you're running inside of yourself
that has you talking about
what you are
right if you're saying you're
complicated and
problematic and hormones are a burden
that's not true
so it's an opinion who gave you that
opinion um
i never had that see i i think there are
definitely definitely scripts and um
patterns and
um
you know absolute ways of thinking that
are
just patterns in society
i
i kind of err on the side of sort of
balance
and so like everything has its natural
balance point and so
meaning i do think that women
have more to deal with like guys don't
have to deal with
the four phases through the month they
don't have to they don't deal and now
keep him hang on let me let me let me
get to the good part at the end they
don't deal with that they don't deal
with the you know having a cycle they
don't deal with bearing a child um so on
this side you have more right but you
get more too like it's these are things
that you have to deal with but on the
other side you have
creativity as a potential like deep
creativity deep connection um uh
understanding recovery and solitude
understanding you know all those
different things and the heightened
potential that is
obtained from maximizing these phases
and then magical things like childbirth
and so i kind of fall on the side that i
think that there's more to deal with
that you get but you get more and so
i would break it down even then too like
just to like the beautiful aspect that
you know women are
amazing beings like we literally are
creation like we are created literally
nothing exists without creation and
that's what we are
well you're not going to have me argue
that point but what i will say is i
would just as i as i share in the book
and as i share all the time when i speak
is that men do have a cycle it just
happens to be 24 hours they do go
through similar phases during the day
i would say it's more challenging for
men because it's happening in a very
compressed fashion
right so they wake up with their testo
they kind of wake up in
their
ludial phase if i had to pick a phase
that they'd wake up in right uh they go
to bed during their menstrual phase they
wake up in their ludial phase it's kind
of a backwards situation
then then there
there's not so much follicular phase
things happening then they're kind of in
the afternoon they're in an ovulatory
social verbal phase right so they have
these
kinds of phases throughout the day the
morning testosterone cortisol surge for
them is um where they're doing their
deep focused high concentration work um
where they can build lots of lean muscle
with strength training very similar to
the luteal phase
where they have to feed their body with
more calories
and all of that
then in the afternoon they have their
testosterone cortisol drop
which is why nootropics are really
popular around male biohackers because
they have to compensate for their loss
in like ability to focus mentally
and stamina so this is something they
have to compensate for they do with
caffeine they do with other nootropics
and but it's also why corporate culture
has happy hour around this time because
this is when men have a little bit more
access to their estrogen which makes
them more verbal and social but then
after dinner
they're now
in their lowest phase of hormones which
is exactly what menstruation phase is
the bleeding phase right the lowest
levels of all your hormones they need to
go into whatever their version of a man
cave is and go to sleep in order for
them to make testosterone for the next
day
so they have a similar cyclical need
and what's interesting is that when you
look at that and you look at
what all the diet and fitness and
biohacking and success hacking and life
coaching suggestions and trends and
things that we just accept as
universally true they're really actually
all designed to optimize for
that male hormonal cycle that happens in
a 24-hour period
and it's a great technique and it's one
that women should be doing too except we
shouldn't be applying it in a 24-hour
clock because we don't
operate that way in our reproductive
years we have
yes we always have a circadian clock
like men do
throughout our whole lives and children
and old people everybody has a circadian
clock
but during
puberty we have sort of this
introduction of an infrared and even a
circuit radiant clock where we have this
other cyclical thing happening in our
body that's affecting our brain our
metabolism our immune system our stress
response system
so it is flawed and illogical to apply
the same self-care routine
to an ecosystem that's not the same
every 24 hours if you're in a female
ecosystem if you're in a male ecosystem
that is absolutely correct and optimal
and it's why you would want to
you know stack your calories early in
the day and stack your workouts early in
the day if you're a guy
but if you're a girl
it depends on which phase of the cycle
you're in it's going to dictate how many
calories you have to eat or which
workouts you're going to do
or anything else for that matter so when
people ask me oh lisa what's your
favorite morning routine
i said well it just depends on which
which phase of the cycle we're talking
about right
because even just that even some of
these assumptions that we make that the
ideal wake-up time is 5 a.m
that's actually to optimize uh for what
happens when testosterone is released
into the bloodstream after men produce
that during sleep right so if if they
wake up at five
they're going to have access to all of
this that's just been released into
their bloodstream along with cortisol
they should get up and take advantage of
that that is not necessarily the case
for you depending on your cycle phase so
it's important for women to navigate
this because if you do
think that that's the ideal
right and you're following those trends
then you start to disrupt these other
rhythms the infrarati and the circuit
trading rhythms
and then you start to have symptoms
across the board with your brain
performance with your metabolism with
your immune system with your stress and
anxiety with your reproductive system
right
and it isn't that you need a different
solution for all these problems it's
that you are disrupting your key
biological rhythm
by applying a methodology that's
optimizing a whole different
gender rhythm
well okay that was great thank you and i
i didn't really look at it like
uh the the sort of timeline being like
month-to-day kind of difference i kind
of just thought guys just have like this
easy little arc of the day they start
off with energy they fade by the end of
the day they start off with energy they
fade by the end of the day but that that
make that that thank you for um
explaining that so then
yeah it feels like obviously the culture
has just adopted this cycle which is not
a one-size-fits-all and so also having
let's say culture went in the direction
of four phases during the month and that
was how
things were oriented in the world
that also wouldn't necessarily work
right everyone's cycle's different so
what it is leading to which is to think
really cool because i'm very much into
spirituality as well i don't know if
that's some an area that you love too
but
it feels like a journey to autonomy
because you can't
it's not literally life like the rhythms
of life are not a one size fit all they
can't be so it's really asking you to go
within and have a sense of where you're
at and how you feel and listening to
that and becoming really sovereign in
your energy and being autonomous in the
world
well the word sovereign is an important
word i think especially for women
um especially because so much when you
aren't properly educated about how your
body works you become
just by default very in a passive
position and you have a sense of not
having agency over your own life and
your own health
so certainly the you know there's an
immediacy around having a reclamation of
sovereignty about just
being able to take action and knowing
what to do when things are going off you
know keeping in mind that
80 of women at some point in their
lifetime will have a hormonal problem
you know which is a staggering statistic
and one in which the male you know sub
set is not there's they're not even on
the same galaxy as far as a percentage
right and of course not right because
they're not setting up their lives to
disrupt their circadian rhythm right so
that's why they're not suffering with as
many hormonal problems but we're because
we're setting up our lives
only to support our circadian rhythm
we're disrupting our infraredian rhythm
and circuitry rhythms and then
we
you know end up with all these hormonal
problems right so it's just it's kind of
crazy but then at the same time
you're right that it would be equally
lopsided to have
the world shift to a you know female
cyclical pattern only what i'm
advocating is that we have
gender inclusivity
but and not even just gender inclusivity
really it's biological rhythm
inclusivity right
because you can be various genders it
just depends on what's happening with
your personal preferences but the idea
is
if you have a circadian rhythm-only
ecosystem or you have a circadian and a
cyclical biological rhythm ecosystem
we just need to include that
in
our research our medical fitness and
nutrition research right now
the female cyclical pattern is left out
of all of that which is
really problematic because the
the trickle-down effect of that is that
we then assume
we're making a very unscientific
assumption when we leave women out we're
just saying oh well they're just
probably smaller versions of men and so
therefore whatever we find for the guys
it was just applied to the girls
i've been a girl for 39 years and it was
all news to me i'm like wow and then i
do this during this time
wow like
so yeah it's news to me
and then you know i think
you know from an autonomy point of view
yes each of us needs to have
a personal understanding so from a
societal point of view i think we should
just sort of strive towards biological
rhythm awareness and inclusivity amongst
you know your relations with people with
in corporate environments i go into
corporations and talk all the time about
how you actually do that in the
workplace
um
it's a different kind of gender equality
it's based on the same
benefits that men get by default you
know
um if i were to sort of define what is a
patriarchy i would look at it through
the biological rhythm lens or the
chronobiology lens and i would just say
well it's a society in which it defaults
to the that particular genders
biological rhythm right and so that's
why they're thriving more right so it's
just you know it's not political it's
just scientific right
and so i think that we should strive for
that on a societal level i think we
should strive for inclusivity on a
research level
and then on a personal level
you just need to own
your operating system right if you've
got a cyclical operating system then you
need to understand how it works and just
give it what it wants and you will be
happy and healthy as a result and then
understand that if you're in a
heterosexual relationship like you know
i understand for example
when i'm with my husband if i want to
have a certain type of interaction with
him i know which time of the day to
approach him for different things based
on his hormonal pattern
and i encourage him actually that
educated him and empowered him i always
joke he could probably teach these
classes too that you know he has to be
that equally aware of my
biological rhythmic reality and know
where i am in my cycle so if he's going
to suggest a night out with friends he
doesn't come to me with that during my
ludial phase or my menstrual phase
because i would look at him like why are
you doing this to me why are you know
like it would be like a burden for him
to make that ask at the wrong time in
the cycle and he knows that so he
wouldn't right that's what gender that's
what biological rhythm inclusivity looks
like let's say in a heterosexual
relationship setting where we just
factor in each other's needs i would
know his testosterone is super low at 11
o'clock at night
maybe i want to approach him for some
fun play time in the bedroom but i would
also then have a certain set of
expectations about how much energy would
have to give to me in that environment
and if i wanted a different kind of
output from him i would approach him at
a different time of the day
because it's just logical it isn't
that's why viagra and all kinds of
stimulants for that are so popular do
you think
swell
so
that's yes and they're also popular
because men are not honoring when they
don't honor that that sleep pattern and
they make and then they don't make the
testosterone that they are supposed to
make
and that starts to decrease as they
start andropause at 25 um men eat
andropause it's the male version of
perimenopause right where they are 25
yes and women start at 35. so men make
less and less testosterone after 25. and
so it's a losing battle with muscle gain
and erection
you know
direction direction
and so
the higher the better
the muscles are struggling
and so the idea is um that if you really
protect your circadian and this is why
the circadian rhythm is such a focus
among male biohackers they wear their
blue light blocking glasses they're
doing certain things to stimulate
themselves throughout the day they're
timing their workouts they're wearing
glucose monitors they're doing all that
they can because the payoff is that they
then get to extend and incr the time
they're making testosterone and increase
the production of that which keeps them
younger longer right so yes viagra i
think is becoming popular among a
younger set even though that's not what
it was originally created for
um
because i think a lot of men do struggle
with lower testosterone than they need
to be
because they're not let's say syncing
with their own cycle properly it's good
for each gender but we have to do it in
two very different ways
right
and i i
i almost was thinking to myself i should
start by asking all the questions that
it has to do that have to do with men
because if there's a man listening and
they start hearing about periods and
cycles and whatever they might go not
for me right like but
it's totally and it's totally for them
to not only understand women because
you're probably gonna be with one or be
with a feminine energy and you're going
to and also
in in understanding the woman you also
by nature understand the man so you
could you literally are kind of could
write the book for men too and how many
guys have written the book for women
none
not well i mean i don't know i'm not
sure i can't i
i i strike that for the record i don't
know
you know what i will say is
that i do think for far too long
we you know as a as a cohort
women we've been
looking for help
you know we've been looking for help
because we don't feel good our weight's
not what we wanted to be our moods our
hormones and so you can kind of look
back at the whole diet and fitness
industry as various types of cries for
help from the female community right
you know
and
and we're all looking for that like
please make i feel like i should my
intuition is telling me that i i should
feel better than i do but i don't and i
don't know why
maybe this workout video will be the
answer maybe this you know uh
no fat diet craze will be the answer
maybe this now intermittent fasting
thing will be the magic bullet that or
the magic carpet ride i can take to the
land where i feel finally what i think i
should feel like which is my best right
but yet none of us have reached that
promised land
because everything that we've been
talked to about
has been researched on men has excluded
our biological rhythm and
doesn't help us get across the finish
line with our health goals so i really
do feel
you know for women that we've
been looking for help but unfortunately
that helped us hasn't been there because
no one has been including our biological
reality yeah and i don't think that
that's necessarily been on purpose but
it is just what it is and so you have to
as a consumer
as a female consumer really look at when
you're reading an article and it says oh
this new study just came in about
whatever hit workouts are the most
magical thing you could do every single
day for your life
you need to go and find the source
research article and you need to read
what the study cohort was was it male
was it post-menopausal women did it
include women in their reproductive
years if not
just don't follow the suggestions
because if it didn't include your
biological reality then it's likely not
going to give you the same result and in
fact now that we have research rolling
in let's say on intermittent fasting and
on hit workouts and other things and
other diet types we know that for women
in their reproductive years this is
actually giving the opposite results of
what the studies found that were so
beneficial for men and postmenopausal
women and why do i keep pulling out
post-menopausal women because once
you're post-menopausal
the infrared and circuit trading rhythms
deactivate essentially and you go back
to a circadian only rhythm like you were
with as a child before pubescence
so you don't need to
cyclically you know
shift your self-care yeah but while you
have an active cycle you bet your bottom
dollar you do and the more you do it the
healthier you will be the less you do it
the more symptomatic you will be period
all the puns intended
um i feel like
yeah women i mean it's like there's this
impossible standard which i kind of want
to talk about yeah but first i want to
talk about like there's this impossible
standard yes
but then there's all these efforts made
to try and figure it out and you know
you do base it on like this is the
newest latest greatest thing i mean even
down to like the things that i've seen
with you know people like i very i very
much have had like a crossfit training
workout schedule for
i mean
87 years and i
and and various different aspects but
then you know i've seen some people that
are like i trained like this and they're
like far too inflamed and once they got
back to different kinds of practices and
they like things just shifted and it's
like wow it just makes you stop and go
we don't have enough information if
something just doesn't simply work
and um
so
yeah and so it's this impossible
standard
as women
are we
are we trying to achieve something
that shouldn't
be achievable meaning
should we feel good every day should we
have high energy should we be high
producing should we look a certain way
should we never age should we have you
know super low body fat should we be you
know great lean muscle mass like is
there an
uh a problem with the objective um
what a fabulous question that is
so
parts of the answer parts i was nodding
to parts of the quest the beginning
parts like should we feel good every day
absolutely should we have high energy
every day absolutely like those types of
things are actually just clear and
straightforward
biofeedback from your body your adrenal
system your nervous system you know all
of these things your immunological
system yes you should be operating at
your
optimal state of flow
right that is that is what nature wants
for you okay and every system in your
body is designed to
make sure that it's maintaining the
homeostasis that's required from us
intracellular level to uh
you know
hormone level to you name it blood sugar
level so that you can
have that optimal
state of being
if we're now shifting to questions
around
physical appearance
whether that be weight
or um
i don't know wrinkles or whatever right
then it comes down to
um
you know i'm somebody who's maintained a
60 pound weight loss for two decades
right
and i did that by
not deprivation not over exercising but
by really putting the focus not on the
weight loss
but on supporting my biological rhythm
right
so i think if you are struggling with
some symptoms that you're not happy with
that are
biofeedback from the body that there
might be inflammation or stress or
disruption right or premature aging
which is not a good thing right
then again the focus should not be
let's say
have liposuction or some extreme thing
to
fix the problem we should look and say
what could i do to more deeply support
the systems that are giving me this
biofeedback that are crying out for help
so it's more just a shift what i like to
call
um you know
active listening and you know
compassionate responding right so
part of the issue is that
you know gloria steinem said this a long
time ago i said this to open up i think
my ted talk a long time ago which is
that from a young age little boys are
taught to view their bodies as a tool to
master their lives and environment
whereas little girls are taught to view
their bodies as a challenge or a problem
that they always have to work on
that is a profoundly different way of
orienting yourself to your life
with your body you know as your partner
right
so
if you were to adopt the mindset that
your body is a tool with which you can
master your life and you do that as a
woman
then if you heard a symptom coming from
your body like excess weight you would
not say gee let me go find uh
xyz fix
it would be okay
what how do i how do i fix this how do i
take action and have leadership around
this issue
such that i that i can see that my body
is getting the inputs that it needs
you know that's it's really that very
simple you change your inputs the body
changes its outputs it's a that's what
biofeedback is all about
so if you want to have weight loss as
for example as a goal
it isn't actually for women just about
reducing restricting calories and
working out more that actually will get
you to gain weight turns out
so i read that and i was like
all these years i've been doing that and
it's just getting me nowhere fast yes in
fact that is exactly where it's
happening so
you know really looking at how do i work
smarter not harder and then i like that
word of like you know shifting the
objectives i don't think it should be on
fixing the problems that you're having
it should be about oh
my body's having a problem which means
i'm screwing up the inputs
what do i do to fix the input so that my
body stops having a problem that i'm
likely creating or at least contributing
in large part to right then that can be
said about weight that can be said about
premature aging that can be said about
um
you know i don't know what
any basically most things right unless
you have some sort of disorder or
genetic factors you know most of these
things that are metabolic um
it really comes down to our inputs i
found it fascinating i'm curious of what
some things that we can do are
but the first thing that that to like
talk about and move aside is i i can't
believe that
like with birth control you don't have a
regular cycle
and i mean that's just crazy to me and
um i don't feel like i was ever told
that i know
i know so
you're right you weren't
that's true i can't i can't can't argue
with that either
yeah and how many times that wants to be
given to you to solve things right right
oh you have this i'll give you that oh i
have this you know um listen victims or
whatever and so what are the
repercussions that's really what i'm
curious about i mean
it's a bummer that we don't know and i
don't know uh maybe they don't know uh
maybe uh but i mean they're they're very
forthcoming now at least to say that you
know these
taking synthetic birth control of any
kind does not fix
you know your pcos or your fibroids it
doesn't it's not a cure
but it's the best tool that they
currently have
based on the very little bit of research
and funding that that research has
received around women's you know chronic
gynecological issues i mean
let's not forget that the most commonly
performed surgical procedure uh is a
hysterectomy because that is seen as the
penultimate solution
after a lifetime of chronic gyn issues
is just to remove the quote unquote
offending organ right which you know if
you think just like put that into
context in the male body
there is no analog surgery
right so
you know but
some 70 year old dude walked into his
gp's office 30 years ago and when the
doc asked him how he was he said
oh hey yeah everything's good i've got a
new younger girlfriend she's 50 you know
what can i do about my erection doc and
then all of a sudden in 1992 because of
the flood of funding that went into the
research to try to solve this problem
for this 70 year old guy that's not
having a life-threatening health problem
or a even all-encompassing health
problem let's say like fibroids is with
pain or endometriosis is with pain right
1992
nitric oxide was named the molecule of
the year
and then we had not one not two but four
medications developed for erectile
dysfunction back in the 90s right i mean
you remember al gore got on the news
talking about his erection right
but we can't put um advertising about
menstruation on facebook or the subway
in new york or i mean it's like but but
al gore can talk about his ed in the 90s
right so
so because there isn't equitable
research and funding taking place the
best treatment that you will hear from a
conventional practitioner is you know
this is what we've got this medication
is the best we've got and that's true
it's the best they've got doesn't mean
it's the best
but it's the best they've got and then
what you should know about it is that it
does not fix
or solve or cure
whatever is wrong with your hormones
what it does do is it shuts them off
you do not ovulate you do not menstruate
so it does that
any bleeding you're having is not a
period it's breakthrough bleeding and
you are uh told your expectations are
set that that might eventually go away
because they don't want you to panic
because you you actually do still think
you're having a period when you're not
right so you're not having a period
period goes away
first thing you should know second thing
you should know is that that the
synthetic hormones strip your body of a
lot of the key micronutrients that your
endocrine system needs to function
optimally at its most basic level like
vitamin d3
and omega-3s and magnesium and
b6 and i mean there's a whole thing
so it's depleting you so it's actually
putting you in a deficit that you may
not have had when you started taking the
medication and then third
how good could we feel if we just fix
this
and then third um
it dr sarah hill wrote a book called
your brain on birth control you're not
actually the same self it turns out it
creates a fundamental personality shift
you're not who you are naturally well of
course because it's shutting off this
whole cyclical rhythm which affects your
brain patterns the female brain 1996 dr
catherine wooley discovered at
northwestern university that the female
brain changes up to 25 over the course
of the month
but then that's taken from you when you
take this medication
a lot of women find that when they're on
that medication they feel confused about
what they want what they're passionate
about from a career point of view then
they go off i cannot tell how many times
this has happened to just with people
i've worked with they go off the
medication all of a sudden they're super
clear they change careers and they
become you know like they have their the
career of their dreams right same thing
can happen with relationships we know
that when you're taking synthetic birth
control you're actually attracted to
someone that you wouldn't normally be
attracted to
and then when you go off the medication
there is a risk that you literally won't
be able to stand the smell of this
person
anymore not to mention you're not an
optimal
immunological match from a reproductive
capacity so um when you're not on
synthetic birth control you're attracted
to someone who is genetically
the most different from you
and you
this is all happens very subconsciously
through you know whether or not we
believe in pheromones those haven't been
actually proven in humans but you know
this whole idea that we are attracted
somehow based on something in the smell
of the person that we're attracted to
that lets us know that they're as
genetically variant from us as possible
which then
increases the chance that you will have
a very healthy offsp child right when
you're on the synthetic birth control
you are attracted to someone who has a
very similar smell you're more
genetically similar and so it can have
effects on your future children's health
right
um you know women are definitely not
aware of all of these consequences when
they're taking this medication and then
what the other really amazing thing is
that
it's 2021 right
we
have technology now that we can use if
if the only reason why you're taking it
is to prevent pregnancy which is a
wonderful reason to have access to birth
control we should have as much access as
we want
if that's what you want
i have some great updates for you okay
which are
first and foremost you need to know that
you're only fertile for 48 hours when
that egg drops right during ovulation
that is the longest viability time for
the egg it doesn't live the whole month
in your uterus right it's just 48 hours
sperm if you're in a heterosexual
relationship which many of you are not
if but if you are
um
the sperm can only live in your body for
five days which gives you a maximum
fertile window of seven days
so just if you think again i am nothing
if not logical if you just think about
the math right why would you
throw a you know a heavy-handed approach
of medicating daily for the reality of
being fertile really a maximum of seven
days
and so it's just kind of a it's becoming
a more outdated approach in my opinion
from a reproductive planning point of
view especially now that we have some
really cool advances in the femtech
community that allow you to have again
sovereignty and agency over your fertile
window right so you can use an app like
the daisy tracker that's going to track
with you know wireless bluetooth your
basal body temperature it's going to
chart it for you you don't have to get
out pencil and paper and do this anymore
or you can use like the mira app which
is going to check your luteinizing
hormones you urinate on a bluetooth
strip and then it measures that hormone
if you don't have an lh surge you're not
you know what i mean it's like there
there are precise ways that you can
measure
ovulation now to the minute
and then
once you have that data you have
agency now you can make some choices you
can use barrier methods
you can you could abstain if you wanted
to if you felt really concerned
um or there's even some new fda approved
products on the market like there's a
product called fexi it's a vaginal
vaginally inserted gel that changes the
ph of your vagina making it completely
inhospitable to sperm they cannot do
what they do
they can't even get to the cervix and it
just comes out on its own you don't have
to do anything you just put it in there
set it and forget it right like a lube
or is it something you use every day no
it's like you use it before intercourse
you know you're gonna have some a
session you just you know stick it in
there and then you know have don't think
about it again right there's no cleanup
so to speak right
and it's safe it doesn't change your
hormones it doesn't cause any problems
so between the device side that can give
you the precise accuracy around your
fertile window
the old school barrier methods from a
heterosexual point of view like condoms
and cervical caps and things like that
and then the new super cool tech i mean
this we have this thing this i
personally feel not that i'm affiliated
with them in any way but i personally
feel like this vaginal gel changing the
ph it's so
new tech it's so
modern and really if you look at these
solutions from
just planning your family planning kind
of needs right
so much more sophisticated than like the
battering ram of you know a daily
hormonal replacement therapy for just a
48-hour window when you're fertile
right
so you there's so much new technology to
take advantage of when you want to
control your reproductive capacity
but when you're trying to fix a hormonal
problem
then that that solution becomes even
more obsolete because it doesn't fix
your hormonal problems and it can make
them worse because of all that
micronutrient depletion so women really
need to know this is why i built flow
living it's the
premier
hormonal healthcare destination from
your first period to your last as
someone who suffered with pcos and saw
the limitations of conventional
um you know approaches to helping
someone like me
i wanted to build a place where you
could go when you're having these you
know problems that can come up when
you're having menstruation when you're
having fertility challenges when you're
having perimenopause where you can come
and get the exact protocols and plans
that you need to just get out of
hormonal chaos and get back into that
state of hormonal flow that you are
designed to be in
yeah
are there some um tests i've i've
actually started to do blood work i'm 39
years old and i have some things that
are going on and i'm like i feel like i
need to get my blood checked so i've
actually i have i've had three blood
draws now and just to kind of figure out
things that are going on and uh other do
you recommend that that be something
that people do regularly only when they
need it and like what kind of tests are
good to know
i mean it depe testing is always for you
know desired outcome right so i think
first and foremost you should always
have an annual hormone panel when you go
to the gynecologist now
they may not want to cover that that's
the problem right so but i do think we
should be annually checking
how we're doing with estrogen
progesterone thyroid all of those things
yeah since we can't often get that
covered by insurance
especially when there are no problems
i think that that's where at home
hormone testing is becoming a really
great solution
um you know where you can you know by
using either dried urine analysis saliva
or even blood spot really get some
accurate information
over time and that's the thing if you're
testing your hormones
for let's just say to see how your cycle
is doing as a whole and keep in mind
the american college of this
obstetricians and gynecologists decreed
that your cycle now be considered a
fifth vital sign right
so it that means you want to take it as
seriously as you take an elevated
temperature right
so if that's the case then we should be
evaluating our cycle as a whole over the
course of a month so a single blood test
is like a polaroid picture
it's a snapshot of what the hormone
concentrations are in your blood at that
particular moment of the blood draw
which is less relevant if you're trying
to see well how is my estrogen changing
throughout the month and what are my
progesterone levels during my ludial
phase it's not as helpful of a test
so that's where some other testing that
you can do at home is is more valuable
if you're doing some baseline testing
day three testing for fertility kind of
evaluation
that's a very good thing to do although
we now know that amh levels i think
women get really concerned about their
amh levels we know for sure that that
doesn't necessarily dictate
how much fertile time you have left
it's about egg quality not egg quantity
it turns out um so don't be overly
concerned about that number if that
number is you know not what you think it
should be the better number to be
looking at
is follicular stimulating hormone right
if your fsh numbers are too high
then that that's a better indication if
you're let's say looking through the
lens of how are you doing from a
fertility point of view that's a much
better indicator of are you prematurely
hormonally aging
because if you're aging too quickly that
fsh number is going to go up and up and
up earlier
fsh you know is the hormone that
stimulates the ovulation process right
if it gets too high the body stops
ovulating this is the whole process of
perimenopause now it begins at 35
for every woman
okay but that's not anything to be
alarmed about think about it again
puberty begins at in the brain it begins
around 9 10 but it doesn't complete
until age 22
okay the whole journey of pubescence
same thing with perimenopause it's a
it's a 10 to 15 year journey easily
so it's good that it starts early and it
takes a long time you tend to not notice
any irregularities in ovulation and
menstruation until your mid to late 40s
if you're taking care of your cycle
which is another reason why the cycle
sinking method that i created which
supports your cyclical hormones right in
your reproductive years is such an
important thing for you to do if you're
if you know you're going to be delaying
your motherhood journey
you want to preserve and protect your um
cycle as as optimally as possible and
the cycle sinking method is really the
best way for you to do that um
and that way you can prolong slow down
that premature aging make sure that
you're not having an a quick rise in
your fsh labels that would be an
indicator a much better indicator of you
know where you are with fertility than
the amhp so although you know it's an
important data point but i would argue
that fsh is more relevant
what are your thoughts on um ivf i and
what that does to the body i did it when
i was 33
and
i don't know i feel like in my in my
intuition i can go
i think everything changed i i mean like
i just think that like it was such a
roller coaster
for
five four or five weeks that you know
and it also was the really the thing
that happened it's in the end the name
of the podcast is pretty intense because
i wrote a book called pretty intense and
the reason why the book came was because
i did that and then i gained five pounds
just
because of hormones and i was like oh my
god hormones are real oh my god it's not
just like eat less it's a real thing
um so uh you know because i know that
this is something that you know i mean i
used it for my own reason because i
wasn't in a situation where i knew my
future so yeah i did it proactively uh
but there are people doing it um in the
moment to try and get pregnant as
quickly as possible because it's it's um
it's something that is hard for them so
you know what are what are what is
really happening to the body and then
perhaps you know for those who have done
it like what's the what's the sort of
fallout or the repercussions of the
recovery
um uh after that much uh
that much control from the outside
instead of the inside
listen i think it is an extraordinary
thing that we have assisted reproductive
technology because
unfortunately we're in a situation where
due to
xenoestrogenic you know chemical
exposure both the fertility rates of men
and women are really on the decline so
this is not just a problem that's
affecting women you know for example the
gl did you know the global sperm count
for men is down 50 percent
across the board i mean this makes like
population such a crap yeah okay keep
going so it's an interesting thing
and so you know i'm i am super
happy whenever there's technology that
helps people medical technology i mean i
think it is a really good thing
fundamentally
um so that's sort of my high level
stance um
what i think
that we could be doing a better job with
is is you know i'm it's going to sound
like i'm repeating myself we should be
doing a better job of educating women
about
how they need to be interacting with
their hormonal self-care
so that they don't end up needing the
most extreme versions of these
interventions right because it's like
cooking you know i like to cook i'm you
know it's like a thing i do for
relaxation and it's kind of like you
know you can always add more salt
to the soup but once you put it in you
really you know it's there you can't
really take it out so similarly if
you're gonna think about you know being
on an ivf journey
it's more it's is it not more logical to
think okay gee
all right maybe i've spent the past 15
years on a hormone suppressant
uh medication like birth control right
which shuts off your hormones okay so
i've done that hmm so that's not optimal
i've had all 15 years of depleting key
micronutrients that support my hormones
and fertility got to do something about
that i've also led a pretty stressful
life where i've been burning the candle
at both ends drinking coffee um
having a lot of you know alcohol to calm
down
um yeah i eat the same kind of
restricted calorie diet every day and i
do like hit workouts every day because
i'm worried about getting and are you
talking about me
you and everybody else sister right this
is this is what happens when we're not
given the right blueprint or the map to
follow
and then you wonder why there's so much
struggle around conception because
conception takes place in the body when
the ecosystem is abundant nutrient rich
hormonally balanced when the nervous
system is you know calm and at
equilibrium when the immune system is
functioning when there's no inflammation
this is what the body wants from a
conception point of view because it is
not just sperm meets egg drop it into
the uterus it's there's a whole
immunological response between the
endometrium the egg the female body
itself it means it's a really delicate
process so you have to come into it like
ripe like a peach you know what i mean
from a from a micronutrient point of
view from a health point of view if you
roll into that process
super depleted having two decades of not
taking care of your hormones
yeah you might need more aggressive
interventions which is neither a good
nor a bad thing it's just more let's
understand how you ended up in that
place and then you can make a decision
about what is reasonable for you if
you're out of time
you know and the only path forward are
aggressive interventions then that's a
reasonable thing to do if you have more
time and you've acknowledged that you've
done everything that kind of interrupts
your body's ability to be optimally
fertile then take some time to rectify
that
right with the well document i mean the
best ivf clinics will often recommend
that you get on a pretty aggressive
micronutrient therapy protocol to boost
your fertility factors before you go
down
the the hormone injectable route right
to prepare for that not in a replacement
of but to prepare
so you know why not take a little extra
time six months one year to
replenish your body to become that juicy
ripe fertile peach version of yourself
and then see what happens because like
cooking you can do a very minimal
intervention with ivf if needed and then
you can keep going from there if needed
you know that would be a way to think
about it if you're concerned about any
of the long-term repercussions and then
there are women who have to really be
concerned
because there's history of
cancers in the family um you know and
you may be uncomfortable taking
synthetic estrogens
you know so it it i think again it just
comes back down to
if you had known because this is all i
hear from people after they encounter my
information is gee i wish i had known
this sooner right so that that's my
question to me to you now is if you had
known this sooner
what would you be doing differently
today and whatever your answer is
that's what you should start doing
immediately because that's going to
shift whatever other healthcare
decisions that are in front of you for
the better
yeah that's so true that's such a great
question too what would you do different
and then just start doing that
um as well as what would you
yeah what would you do different and
trying to pass along that message right
i think first and foremost it's like you
look at
you know synthetic birth control like
right off the bat and go
okay this is this is like a quick fix if
i just put a little bit of effort into
understanding myself a little bit better
can i take control of that and then and
we're so capable of it as women like
let's just think about the collective
right the collective mind
share and the collective energy output
that goes into all the um like things
that women have tried from
i mean
people spend time doing jade rolling and
vaginal steaming and you know intense
workout commitments and
women do not lack
discipline and will power when they're
committed to having something you know
to trying something
so just just channel that same energy
that you have been putting into the
wrong solutions
and put them into this just what's
needed for your actual hormonal pattern
it's not overwhelming it's not confusing
the book in the flow lays it out chart
by chart eat this at this time do this
workout at this time it doesn't have to
feel like this complicated thing and
you're more than capable of doing very
complex
i mean think of think of any of you
who've done like a really
intense cleanse you know and you're
having like
a special juice in the morning and then
like certain things at 3 pm and like you
know you're super capable of doing
complicated things this is way less
complicated than that this is literally
going with your biological flow
and it's just channeling that energy
into
going downstream as opposed to paddling
against the current yeah
i agree and i think um
so true and there's so much too that i'm
thinking about about mindset too and
like you know stress in your life and
that level huge you know uh i know and
how that plays into your
um into your biology and how everything
is working and so we might think we feel
okay but like when we really take stock
and we really go inward and do the work
like there's obviously the things that
we can do from an eating perspective
from fitness
from um
the energy of the sort of the flow of
the cycle and what what call what is
what is serving us best if we don't look
at the way we think and the way we look
at ourself and how we say yes to
ourselves because i feel like this whole
thing is kind of looping around to
really like
that sort of sovereignty and that
accountability
for yourself and really saying yes to
yourself
because
that is
the most empowering thing that you can
do and the more that you honor yourself
the more you will reciprocate that and
honor others and so it's really like the
form of self-care is really
it's not selfish it's uh it's completely
serving for the self and others i feel
well back to your creative you know that
creation energy that you're talking
about but yes i mean i think that
there's a real
opportunity for women to not only come
home to their bodies
but also
to
heal so many different things like you
know we talked earlier about maybe
uh impossible standards i like to think
of it as like more of this
pathology that we have around
perfectionism that we think that we're
supposed to be perfect
i actually think that's just a misplaced
uh sort of language around what we think
we're supposed to be is the same every
day right because if you
take all the inputs that are coming from
various sources which optimize the male
hormonal pattern which is the same every
day then somewhere in your subconscious
mind you have made a link between
good equal
same and if you want to be good then
you're going to try to force yourself to
be the same every day and that creates a
lot of psychological turmoil for
yourself because you
do not feel the same every day and then
you just instantaneously start to feel
badly about yourself so that's the first
thing that will go away because now you
don't have that conflict there is no
inner conflict you are not trying to be
the same
good now
equals dynamic
not same right good equals dynamic so
you're going to shift
right you're going to be different every
day
and that's good
kids you love them they're different
like you can love yourself good but
different right just like kids like
different right everything doesn't have
to be the same exactly
and so we get rid of this perfectionist
thing and it frees up so much energy
and we feel happier and more positive
about how we relate to ourselves then
the other thing is too this is like a
measurable stress level reduction right
because
if you are eating the right caloric
intake at the right time of your cycle
your cortisol levels are lower
as opposed to what happens when you
force yourself to have the same calorie
level every day you're going to jack up
your cortisol levels right and that's
stress this is so when i talk about
stress i i like to actually
like really get down to the hormone
cortisol because it isn't this like
mental thing stress it's a physiological
response that we're having if you do the
same hit workout every day of the cycle
you're going to jack up your stress
levels if you modulate your workout
intensity based on your cycle phases
your stress levels come down so when
your stress levels come down
your anxiety levels come down and when
those things come down guess what boot
goes way up
creativity and productivity because we
none of us have more time in the day but
if we learn how to optimize our
biological rhythms we can have much more
energy
throughout the day and you know harvard
business review talks all about but all
the time about
we as a corporate culture should not be
focusing on time management but energy
management and i couldn't agree more but
men and women have to do that
differently
and so if you want to be more productive
if you want to be more creative then
you've got to get out of the
perfectionist trap by just understanding
that you are not the same creature every
24 hours
and drop that whole struggle and trying
to be that just
never going to happen let it go you will
after your menopausal so you can have it
then and you can have it when you're a
kid
and then
um you know do the right things from a
self-care point of view at the right
phases of your cycle measurably keep
your cortisol levels where they should
be and boost your productivity
effortlessly right without increasing
your stress everybody wants to know how
can i do more
but not burn myself out well
the cycle thinking method will allow you
to do that and notice that it is not a
diet it's not a plan it's a method you
apply this method in various ways
and it's something that you will
customize for your own individual self
and there is no need to get it perfectly
right not even
even if you just did it 50 of the time
you would yield a huge improvements
in supporting your biological rhythm
right think about it this way
if you
get no sleep
you feel horrible during the day right
if you get
50 of the sleep you should be getting
you feel okay you can you can do it and
if you get
80 of the sleep you should get you feel
pretty great right you're happy with
that same thing goes with the cycle
sinking method you do not have to be a
perfectionist with this either
and that's a relief because nothing in
nature is perfect you're not perfect you
don't have to do this perfectly you just
have to make the attempt to support
yourself and meet your biological
reality where it is in real time and you
will get huge dividends back from your
body your hormonal balance your mood
your creativity your productivity your
sexual response i mean we haven't even
talked about the fact that 67 of women
are sexually unsatisfied that really
comes down to the fact that you don't
even know
what your sexual response is supposed to
look like across the month right it's
different it's not supposed to be the
same every day so you shouldn't have
that expectation and when you drop that
in proper expectation
you can actually have a you know you can
biohack your orgasm it turns out that's
in chapter nine so you know it's all
laid out for you there should be no more
mystery about how your body works and
what you need to do to optimize it um
because i put all the research into the
book and and it's just there for you
waiting for you to to unlock for
yourself yeah it definitely does i
didn't want to take this time to
have you articulate all the cycles and
all the food and all that actually
because it's in the book like it's in
the book
in the book if you're curious which i
was very curious i just read it about as
quick as i've read a book um so is there
anything uh so thank you and i'm i want
i encourage people even guys like to to
kind of like you know have it in the
house and check it out and you know you
know [ __ ] you know be interested uh it's
a form of love connection it's a form of
connection 100 great way to boost your
intimacy yeah i care about the person is
there is there anything coming down the
pipeline as far as um
you know research or
having more women be in those trials or
trials that have been done with uh with
women to kind of give us better
information um i i totally want to ask
about intermittent fasting and keto and
fasted cardio and all kinds of things
but you know for another day is there
anything coming down the pipeline uh
that is exciting
i hope so i but nothing that i'm aware
of at the moment that specifically you
know i'm i'm here advocating for that
inclusivity and for that specificity
um you know i i i think i made a call
out at the end of the book for here's
some research i'd love to see
you know so you know i think that
what's interesting now is that there is
a little bit more awareness that women
do need some special research being done
on their reproductive years
how our immune response is different how
our metabolism is different so i think
that the research is going to start
increasing
but we're we're nowhere near where we
should be
yeah at all um as far as
hard data is concerned
we'll just have to do our own research
and you know on some level we're all
just a little different anyway so in the
meantime
uh
figure yourself out pay attention say
yes to yourself say yes to sovereignty
from all things
take your power take your part using the
cycle thinking method because your your
cyclical pattern though it may vary
you know your friend may have a 28-day
cycle you may have a 32-day cycle
you may have different hormonal problems
the fact of that is your cycle is
supposed to function the same way across
the board we all are supposed to have
these four specific phases
so start taking care of them
and that that will that will lead you
down the right path for sure
thank you so much for um
sharing information that is brand new
for some
for most women which is kind of sad to
say but it's very exciting at the same
time
i like to focus on the exciting part
and if you need resources and you're you
know you're struggling with your period
or your fertility or your perimenopause
you know that's what flowliving.com is
all about come come be with us there
we're here to support you with our
products and programs um if you're
excited about you're in freidian and
circuitradian rhythms and you want to
support that you can come to the
cyclesyncingmembership.com
if you want to just learn which phase
you're in you know i built an app that
is the only cycle syncing method app
called myflow
myflowtracker.com make sure it has a
circle icon
like the one on the cover of in the flow
and um you know you can find me on
instagram at flowliving and alisa.vd so
you can check me out there if you want
some ongoing information
yeah well thank you very much thank you
i really appreciate it thanks everybody
for listening to the pretty intense
podcast today i hope you enjoyed it if
you like what you heard today and you
want to hear more please click on the
subscribe button